je savais que les élèves avec qui
j'étais et eh bien j'avais vraiment
l'impression que tout était sous
contrôle mais le lendemain de la
diffusion le téléphone s'est mis à
sonner il y avait des gens qui me qui
voulait me voir en entrevue qui voulait
m'avoir aux émissions télés radios se
vexe des jeux fdj tous refusé parce que
mon rôle pour moi c'était d'être avec
mes élèves
j'ai fini ma journée travail plus en
vente dans la voiture je voulais tous
les soirs j'écoute toujours les mêmes
postes de radio avait ce soir là il est
en train parler de moi beaucoup de gens
étaient assez secoué par ce qu'ils ont
vu hier soir et ça pousse toutes sortes
de questions sur bon la pertinence n'est
qu'un tel exercice comme soldats j'étais
démolissent existe elle a fait ça
vraiment créer un doute
j'ai toujours eu ce doute là toujours
c'est ce qui est particulier c'est
d'avoir que cette leçon là que je
faisais pour mes élèves mais elle sert
aussi à d'autres élèves du primaire ou
même secondaires ou du cégep dans plein
de situations quand je vais au dépanneur
ou quand je vais à des cours de danse
pour mes enfants je rencontre des jeunes
qui me faisait ça est ce que c'est vous
est ce que l'enseigné saint-valérien
djibson à mon cours de toutes sortes de
raisons en français au secondaire au
cégep eux c'est particulier les gens
vous reconnaissent encore aujourd'hui et
certains puis d'autres comme tout à
l'heure je perdais avec une collègue une
nouvelle collègue qui est ici depuis
cette année qui se demandaient pourquoi
vous étiez dans l'école puis l ovulation
discrimination mais jamais associé que
c'était moi